yo so i've been seeing the way you've
been talking online benny and i've i've
i i see eye to eye with you and that is
essentially
for the last two years right 2018 2019
you dropped projects that were in
the discussion for best projects of the
year classics right so like
back to back years and you've been
kind of quiet this year i mean outside
of touring
and doing all the griselda [ __ ] and
hopping on and just bodying everybody's
albums that's not your own [ __ ]
um but i've been seeing you talking that
talk like listen once the
once the floodgates open up i'm about to
take this whole this year is mine
yeah yeah cause i'm about to open them
up and what i've been doing is
i'm just at the chessboard and and and
i'm looking for a checkmate
i found it you know what i'm saying
though i could take pieces and all that
i've been setting up a checkmate and
from
july 31st mark my words from july 31st
when uh respected sopranos come out dj
drama
black soprano family from that day to
the end of the year i'm taking over
for the past three straight years all my
all my albums been
in the top 10 of the year for sure i've
been having versus top 10 complex
for the past three years you know what
i'm saying so it's nothing going to stop
it's just i've been elevating and i've
been lining up my moves
yo i saw you better than the next one i
saw you tweeted yesterday that
you're gonna do tana talk four and five
together
yeah yeah double album yeah yeah and i
want none of you rap [ __ ] to steal my
idea either
you what i'm saying i'm gonna do tender
talk four and five that's gonna be a
double album
double album i'm assuming you're sitting
on so much music bro
if you know and one thing about me if i
if me benny the butcher haven't dropped
in 14 months you know what i got i got
that's what i'm saying fault of [ __ ]
cause your squad like you know the
griselda team man you guys put out
music at it at a at a high rate
that actually i would say this i like i
like the way that you drop
projects because it feels like you like
you said like tana talk three was
i mean flawless just rap music plugs i
met
but it but the squad like yo man we got
so much you know just
amazing music coming from like if you're
not dropping
guns dropping conway's dropping exactly
and i'm on all their projects so
that's kind of feel like people will be
a little appetizer you know like
to keep your fans people been starving
for that solo project but you know what
i'm saying i've been all over the place
i'm in
a little wayne album this year uh
this is about to come out russ
uh gibbs yo the gibbs [ __ ] is crazy
8